[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
assez lent bouddhiste et hindouiste ont
rendu hommage aux dieux catarragama
après s'être baigné dans les eaux du
fleuve sacré les fidèles ont célébré
leur Dieu selon des pratiques qui
n'exclut pas les séculaires clous
plantés dans la chair et les crochets
piqués dans le dos pendant deux semaines
la foule des fidèles se livra des danses
et à des réjouissances qui laissent
libre cours à leur enthousiasme
religieux car le peuple saint-galletre
est mystique manifeste sa croyance de
façon diverse et non dénuée
d'originalité les éléphants Richmond
arnacher prennent part à la procession
qui célèbre une croyance très ancienne
ainsi assez lin les rites religieux se
perpétuent à travers les siècles sans
rien changer
de Dieu porc à Zeebruges le mouvement
populaire flamand a manifesté par un
défilé automobile qui couvrait des
kilomètres et qui mêlaient les marques
et les cylindrées sont mécontentement de
voir la langue française dominée sur le
littoral sur son passage à hostende ce
cortège a été l'objet de contre
manifestation et la police a dû
intervenir à diverses reprises pour
maintenir l'ordre
flambée de la guerre linguistique qui
provoque des dissensions en Belgique des
huées et des acclamations des
bousculades et des explosions de pétards
ont marqué cette marche sur la côte qui
n'a fait sans doute ni l'affaire des
commerçants ni celle des touristes en
ville légiatures
[Applaudissements]
l'affaire du train postal Glasgow
Londres aura une place de choix dans les
annales du gangstérix c'est en effet le
plus gros hold-up de l'histoire
criminelle les gangsters ont raflé plus
de 3 milliards et demi d'anciens francs
la police d'abord n'a plus que
reconstituer l'histoire comme dans les
meilleurs westerns les bandits ont
arrêté le train en pleine campagne
ligoter les postiers enlevez 109 sacs
postaux bourrés de billets de banque
bientôt pourtant enquête et ratissage
portaient leurs fruits on découvrait
l'affaire isolée ou les bandits avaient
ramené le butin et la fosse qu'ils
avaient creusé pour y faire disparaître
les sacs postaux et Scotland garde
market un point important elle arrêtait
deux femmes et trois hommes et récupérer
120 000 livres provenant du hold-up un
blackout complet règne sur ses inculpés
dont l'interrogatoire continue premier
pas sur une piste qui mènera on l'espère
jusqu'au cerveau qui organisa
l'opération on le sait le crime ne paie
pas
[Musique]
on sait que à Copenhague comme
d'ailleurs dans le Danemark entier tout
le monde va à bicyclette le vélo s'il
n'est pas un sport national n'en est pas
moins une habitude nationale mais
l'abondance de ces transports
particuliers crée des problèmes combien
de vélo en rupture de parking ou en
contravention avec la loi or la loi
n'est pas tendre et voici tout
simplement ce qui arrive
et voilà tout ce qui peut se consumer
brûle allègrement
et quant au reste un passage à la presse
en fera sous une forme ou même un
cycliste chevronné ne reconnaîtrait pas
un cadre en fera un bloc d'excellente
ferraille et l'industrie du vélo car
tous enchaîne retrouvera de nouveaux
clients dont les bicyclettes un jour ou
l'autre mais il est inutile d'achever
[Musique]
à l'allongement des silhouettes imposées
par les couturiers pour la saison
prochaine les modistes ont répondu
d'accord et Jean Barthès il y ajoute des
ailes à mouvement chasseurs de coureurs
de prairies à développer en hauteur
toutes les calottes de ses créations
[Musique]
marie-Christiane qui met l'agréablement
velours feutre et fourrure passe
facilement du chasseur ravissant c'est
le mot au casque dit de Jeanne d'Arc
mais pourquoi Jeanne d'Arc
[Musique]
pour Georgette de 13 c'est la forme du
casque encore qui sert de base à
l'élégance de la saison et c'est une
prémonition dans ce triste été d'un
nouvel hiver rigoureux voici la toque de
fourrure irremplaçable finition d'une
élégance qui n'a pas peur de dire son
nom Alaska et son prénom Paris
[Musique]
est vide passant rare magasin fermé dans
la rue des herbes un chien qui est
abandonné c'est l'un des drames des
vacances
ils sont trop nombreux ceux qui au
moment du départ soucieux de ne pas
s'encombrer mais oubliez d'une affection
même ancienne abandonne sans complexe le
petit compagnon qui partagea un moment
de leur vie MUF le sans cœur ou égoïste
sans pitié
et chaque année revoit le spectacle de
ces bêtes qu'on laisse au hasard parfois
même en leur fermant la bouche d'une
bande de sparadrap pour éviter les longs
appels
on ne dira jamais assez l'intérêt de
l'oeuvre de charité rempli chaque année
à cette époque par la Société
protectrice des animaux qui dépêchent
ces équipes à travers la ville pour
retrouver ou prendre à domicile les
pauvres bêtes et leur assurer un asile
et la nourriture quotidienne
au refuge de Gennevilliers chiens et
chats retrouvent un peu de la chaleur du
foyer refusé
[Musique]
à cette saison le refuge est plein plus
de 300 chiens plus de 200 chats y
attendent que la vie leur rende ce
qu'ils ont perdu
beaucoup d’ailleurs retrouveront par
bonheur la chaleur d'un foyer car chacun
peut venir ici chercher un compagnon le
cas des bêtes si cruellement abandonné
n'en est pas moins un drame drame de
l'égoïsme drame de la cruauté humaine
vous qui partez en vacances sont Jésus
[Musique]
les trains de vacances qui vivent les
grandes villes à l'époque du mois d'août
laisse au milieu des rues des peuplées
une race singulière d'hommes seuls les
célibataires du mois d'août les aousiens
on les voit à l'heure où leur travail
finit et rénaux Challans sans doute mais
saisis tout de même par les nécessités
quotidiennes auxquelles ils n'ont pas
généralement à faire face
grand problème de la houssien le
blanchissage il sentir généralement au
rayon lingerie d'un magasin ces coûteux
mais facile et puis pense-t-il ça
servira toujours
[Musique]
autre problème les repas chose curieuse
là où si un ne recherche pas le
restaurant il fréquente plutôt le
magasin d'alimentation pour satisfaire
probablement à une funeste passion de
cordon bleu qui la réfréné toute l'année
là où si c'est le client idéal pour
libre-service son sens pratique lui
réserve de grandes joies au rayons des
ustensiles ménagers
comment a-t-on pu se passer si longtemps
d'une pareille rappe à fromage
[Musique]
naturellement il y a des déboires
tous ces menus soins du ménage aux
travaux ennuyeux et facile comme le
disait Verlaine crée sans doute une
oeuvre de choix n'est qu'un apprenti de
génie n'est pas toujours de taille à
dominer
pour moins que cela va-t-elle se passer
son épée au travers du corps mais
monsieur Durand n'est pas Vatel si elle
a ses complications la vie de là où sien
a ses joies les joies sévères du devoir
accompli que confirme le petit mot
trouvé sous la porte les autres se
paient du bon temps là-bas ici il est
seul aux prises avec la vie le beau rôle
est pour lui il se sent presque un héros
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]